hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and this is tamara has never seen and
today I am watching Blues Brothers 2000
I was in the nostalgia critic review of
Blues Brothers 2000 I've not seen the
film though and I've heard the worst
things about it maybe a very honest with
everyone right now and I prepared for a
lot of harsh backlash I didn't love the
original blues brother I really loved
the music in it and I appreciated it and
I mean I love the actors in it the
cameos were great but overall I found it
to be kind of boring I'm going in like
open-minded like I hope I really enjoy
it I hope like the music is redeeming I
hope it has a funny story but I don't
have high
[Music]
r.i.p Tara's never cease I can't go out
at the Lord help me ah no well that was
one of the worst films I've ever seen in
my entire life I was very tempted to
just fast-forward through a lot of those
scenes sucks because this movie from
what I've gathered is supposed to it was
supposed to be like a tribute and it
wasn't so we start off and Dan Aykroyd
is getting released from prison and he
stands outside and waits for like a day
and a half and I think it's supposed to
be funny but it's not in the first one
Aykroyd picks up Belushi and in this one
psycho setting it up for like Belushi
picking up a girlie but of course it's
not going to happen white ah so then he
gets picked up by a dancer from his
friends club as her take him to the
orphanage and that's where we really get
just the bulk of what's about to happen
for some reason he is getting the band
back together
and then again and then another for some
reason he has to have a kid why is it
buster
and then also you find out that curtis's
past as well and Curtis had a son and so
he's got a purpose now Aykroyd is gonna
go and he's gonna go get the son and
then they're gonna start up the band
again cuz why the not why don't we just
do exactly what we did in the first but
so much worse really the makings of all
great sequels unfortunately I feel kind
of similarly to the first of this
there's a lot of scenes that are just
super unneeded there's a scene where he
he doesn't connect with Curtis his son
the commander he steals his wallet
instead to go get the car back and he
gets the car back and he has a very long
conversation with the car dealership guy
who says that he's gonna quit tomorrow
and move to New Orleans and that's cool
I'm so happy for the car salesman but it
doesn't need to be there it's like a
really long drawn-out not funny scene
that definitely doesn't need to be there
after he stole the wallet we could have
just assumed he was going to get the car
with the money that was like his whole
intention the scenes were so long the
songs were the most enjoyable parts
mcfar by far by far they were still like
they were dragging they were just so so
so so long they were also exact replicas
of the first movie slightly different
tweaks but even the same dance moves
like down to back and like the same
premises and all of it it's like getting
the band back together and finding this
one person from the band and then like
oh I can't because of my life are like
this whole day like it's just like the
same premise just way way less work put
into it and much poorly done much more
done poor poor doesn't
malfunction I wrote okay okay okay okay
okay okay okay john goodman singing that
i'm looking for a fox it's pretty good
okay john goodman is a treasure and i
loved him in this film he tried his best
to add a little bit of charisma and was
honestly a lovely if you have to do the
replacement gave a lovely replacement
should have made it did you guys know
that there's an n64 game for this that
came out two years after the movie was
released who came for
who is gonna flick at that game and
enjoy it who actually mattered they have
all these gigs and there's no reason for
them to be doing these gigs there was in
the first one there's not in this one
and so now they're just like evading the
law and death from russians oh then
there's like a big police chase you get
the puffball bacteria I was gonna do it
I was gonna put it all in my face and be
like this isn't even funny prefer but I
don't have the fluffy kind of shaving
cream I just have the silky kind of
shaving cream that thing about this
reaction video is good it's just like
you know you've hit rock bottom I wrote
so the band is back together now at this
point they're back together they're
running from the cops and the Russians
but they're not like the goal isn't
really the goal is just to do a couple
gigs I guess like what else could there
possibly be I checked the time and
there's an hour left no so sure let's go
play a Bluegrass Festival so sure let's
cause a huge storm and cause Ghost Rider
to appear so sure let's just crush
cameras hopes and dreams so they're at
the Battle of the Bands and the cops are
there the van
is there the Illinois Nazis and the
Russians are there back when white
supremacists and Russians didn't like
each other but then the Illinois Nazis
and and the Russians are turned into
into rats somehow you hear that Ike you
would love this movie and like the cops
are kind of cool with it and they all
jam together then the cops aren't cool
with it and then Buster and Elroy okay
epic Roy and busted just drive on along
out into the sunset yeah sometimes it's
fun to not like films for Tamra's never
seen like usually I like things so
sometimes it's fun for a movie to be so
bad that it's like I can't wait to just
like yell a whole review of reaction but
this wasn't that this was not fun you
will see what the hell at least ten
times I said what the you'll be torn
between genuinely great music and the
genuinely awful well everything else the
music didn't redeem it at all for me
like the music was obviously like really
cool is great to see some of these
amazing people BB King and Eric Clapton
but there's still like an hour and a
half of like actual movie outside of the
song so it's just like it's miserable
don't jump on the hate train remember it
wasn't just Elwood you lost a brother
there are simply no words for when
something like that happens it's a movie
about how to move on after such a loss
his musical family his SNL family all
came to remind him of what family really
is and then the next person said nah
mate it's a sequel caching I really
assignment I really enjoy the thought of
bats I wanted it to be that and I
understand maybe working on it maybe
hopefully working on it was was really
nice for all of them see each other
again to come together after that loss
but it wasn't well executed and so I
don't hate the
idea of that I don't hate the sentiment
but I do hate the problem copy/paste
repeat a sequel that manages to
misunderstand everything that made the
original amazing yes it's a better
sentence than this whole ten minutes so
what I just said but yeah that's
basically what it is I'm sorry if you
like this movie I hate like just really
going in hard against things that people
like but you know I did not enjoy this
at all I feel better now yelling and
making terrible noises at a camera for
ten minutes that's good
next week I am watching the first Muppet
film I've never seen any of the Muppet
movies so I'm watching the 1979 version
thank you so so much for watching I'll
see you guys next week
ah yes I'll go shave my face now it
wasn't due for another week but I mean
here we go
[Music]
[Applause]
you